[Music]
well all of this week we're going to be
bringing you special stories on pets
training social socializing exercising
and here at six o'clock tonight we start
with fostering
fostering or giving pets a temporary
home gets them out of that stressful
shelter environment
and then into a happy home and for some
failing at fostering
is really a win for both pets and people
when the world closed its doors in 2020
come here
caroline ciocca opened her heart i
definitely wanted a dog
but i wanted the right dog she loves
carrots after spotting stella at the
shelter she knew she was cute
but what kind of companion would she be
take her home
take her out of the shelter she's
probably going to be a different dog
so fostering was the perfect way for me
to
experience that well oh that's a good
job
it's a trial run for both owner and
animal
they give you so much back it's so worth
it kate mclaughlin has fostered
so many kittens she's lost count this is
when everybody wants them right
but they're not ready to be adopted yet
they need some time to grow up
they need to learn how to be how to be a
cat and they need to get to the point
where they can be fixed
before they can be adopted out adoption
is the end goal
but getting there might mean time and
foster care as an
animal is going out there are countless
others waiting to come in
fostering truly does save lives i can't
say that enough
the nspca is in the midst of kitten
season which could last until the fall
for young animals nursing moms senior
dogs
the shelter is a stressful place so
giving them a reprieve can allow them to
relax
have a better way of knowing what
they're like and to find them their
perfect forever home is a lot easier
when we know what their personalities
are
for stella it didn't take long at all i
knew the first day that i had her that
she wasn't going back i need to sit here
and do this all day
her foster and eventual adoption created
life-saving space for
another little soul she's just a joy to
have around
cute dog right not only does she have a
home stella has her own instagram page
rescued by stella if you'd like to
follow her